-I want to congratulate you.
I know I've talked to you
a little,
but I don't think you've bee
here since "Shrill" came out
-It's true.
-It's just a fantastic show.
-Oh.
-And you have a second season.
And you're gonna film it out
in Portland this summer, right
-Yes, I damn am.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I know --
You know, it was so great
because obviously you have
a show like that.
And it is very much your show.
You are driving the show.
I know you have a hand
in creating the show.
And when you do press about it
it must be different
than when you get
interviewed about "SNL"
because it is a far
more personal show.
-Totally, yeah.
I mean, the show is about, like,
a woman finding
her self-confidence
and hating her body and deciding
to stop hating herself.
And so, you know, like, "SNL,"
they're like,
"What's it like
in the wacky wigs?"
And then when I do
press about "Shrill,"
the questions are like,
"So you've hated yourself
for many years."
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like, "Yeah!"
And it's -- There's nothin
like back-to-back digging in
with people being like, "So,
must be tough to wear T-shirts."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "Yeah, I guess."
-Your husband, Conner,
who's a wonderful guy,
who I've known for a long time
and your family,
did they have a different
experience watching the show
versus watching you on "SNL"
-Yeah. I think they were
weirdly more nervous for i
because it is so much more
personal and it is, like,
you know, a little bit --
There's --
Parts of my life are in there.
And I think for them
it was a lot to take
because there's, like,
some sex scenes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know?
Yeah, if you want to see my ass,
check it out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a resounding "yes.
-That's a -- If you want it,
you've got it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do what I have to
to make money.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
This is all about money.
This is not titillating for her.
It's just about money.
-Cash.
[ Laughter ]
-The season finale is this week.
-Oh, yeah.
-You've had a great season
And you did some impressions
this year,
and you did one of Anne McClain,
who is a female astronaut.
-Yes.
-And she tweeted.
-From space!
-From space.
From space she tweeted,
"I am still laughing about this,
and, Aidy, your uniform
looks impeccable!"
-I can't handle it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Because, I mean,
it's easily the coolest thin
that's ever happened to me
It means that she watched
the sketch in space.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-My face has been to space
Like -- Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was the coolest thing.
And she gave, like -- In space
she gave an interview about it
where they, like, asked --
she's floating in the air an
they're like, "Did you like it?"
And she was like, "It was
the laugh we needed this week.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Are you telling
me I'm helping the astronauts?
[ Laughter ]
It touched me so --
It was easily the coolest thin
that's ever happened to me
-That is fantastic.
-Yeah.
-I am a little sad
that Twitter made it to space.
-Yeah.
-You know, just in general
-And I hear you.
-Yeah, I feel like it is a virus
that I hoped we could
contain on our planet.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
-It's spreading.
-You're right.
-It's spreading to the --
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-Meghan McCain was on the show
You did a Meghan McCain
impression this year,
and she was here
and she was talking about
how she enjoyed that.
You guys have
a crazy connection.
-Yeah, it's really --
We're both Arizona women.
That is true.
And we weirdly -- We also
went to the same high school
-Yeah.
-And so I watched her
on your show.
And in it she's like,
"Yeah, you know, Aidy and
went to the same high school."
And she, like, shouts out
our high school,
and is like, "Whoop, whoop
Yeah, Xavier College Prep!
And I definitely was like,
"Oh, man, we had different
experiences of high school."
[ Laughter ]
Like, I was like, "For her
it was a 'whoop, whoop!'"
[ Laughter ]
And for me it was
the darkest opposite.
[ Laughter ]
And I really was like,
"Oh, okay, okay."
Like, I'll tell you,
I recently found a self-portrait
that I drew in class of myself
in high school.
I think you have it.
-Yeah.
-But just to warn you before you
show it, it's incredibly scary
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
But I think it's fun to know
that, like, Meghan McCain
in her mind,
high school is "Whoop, whoop!"
And for me it's this,
which is...
[ Laughter ]
This is -- Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think something that I lov
about -- It's very subtle.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And that's --
My school had a uniform.
So I'm wearing the uniform
and I'm behind bars.
[ Laughter ]
And then I assume that's
sort of blood on the walls
[ Laughter ]
Or sort of red paint.
-They were like,
"Aidy, we got your submissio
for the yearbook cover."
[ Laughter ]
"And we are going to
go another way."
-And that is fair.
I have to say it was,
like, 2005.
It was kind of cool to be emo,
and I was living that very hard.
[ Laughter ]
Dipping my toe into goth.
-I do think people that go
"Woot, woo"
are not the ones
who end up in comedy.
So I do think that it make
sense that you ended up
being the version of
Meghan McCain that's on "SNL."
-Yeah, absolutely, begging
people, in wigs, to like me.
For sure.
[ Laughter ]
-So we mentioned your husband,
Conner.
You guys went to Italy.
-Yes.
-This summer?
-Well, yeah, this past summer.
-This past summer and you --
you went to a cheese factory
I guess?
What do you call it?
-Absolutely, cheese factory.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah, I mean, we went to
Italy which --
they were like,
"Oh, it's the most romanti
place for a honeymoon.
Oh, the romance."
And right away when we
got there, they were like,
"There's also a cheese factory."
[ Laughter ]
And we were like,
"That's for us."
[ Laughter ]
And while we were there,
one of the women was like,
"You need to slow down
eating the cheese."
[ Laughter ]
"There's such a long day.
You must not eat
all this cheese."
But here's --
I think this is a --
We had to wear
full-body condoms to go...
[ Laughter ]
...into the cheese factory
But it's the -- Still to thi
day, it's guiding our marriage
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And how does it work?
I mean, is it just like --
they just are constantly, like
saying, "This is what this
cheese tastes like"?
-Okay, well, it was only
one kind of cheese.
[ Laughter ]
It was Parmigiano-Reggiano
And it's basically
you're just watching men
who are exhausted
and are working so hard.
And you're, like, watching the
lift, like,
huge chunks of cheese.
[ Laughter ]
And then you kind of walk around
and taste it.
And we still talk about it
probably once a week.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
That is outstanding.
Living the dream.
-Abs-- This is love.
[ Laughter ]
-It is so exciting that you're
gonna do season two of "Shrill."
-Thank you.
-And it is so great that
this week is the season finale
Another great year for you
Give it up, everybody.
Aidy Bryant.